Mexico City home to 20 million people
most of them Catholics the church
forbids any dealings with witchcraft
saying it's the work of the devil
but for many Mexicans the allure of
magic both good and evil is irresistible
get this the other believers find the
tools of witchcraft at the Senora
witches market this is a this is a
afro-caribbean anthropologist Anthony
zabaleta has studied the market for 25
years in every cranny of this maze bruja
or witch doctors peddle their cures it's
a market for even the most gruesome
wares along with goods the market
provides services in back rooms behind
the stalls nearly anything is possible
spells can be cast or lifted customers
can have their spirits cleansed or
engage in satanic rites it's all here
Persis Bly powered by wing of bat and
tongue of pit witches bind hexes in
black ribbon ready for burial in a human
brave curses like these are all too
familiar to doctor zabaleta as part of
his research zabaleta has been studying
with Alberto Salinas Vidia a healer
who's come all the way from Texas
Alberto is here to restock his hex
fighting kit
believe in witchcraft was just an
abstract idea for doctors a Valletta
until he had his own life-changing
encounter with black magic zabaleta was
traveling with alberto and other healers
on a mission what we found in what we
saw that day was just unbelievable in 30
years of research field research into
Brooke idea including Diddy's Moen I had
never encountered anything like that and
probably never will again they came to a
site where black magic was rumored to
take place doctors a Valletta videotaped
the events that followed let's show it
up here Alberto what is it all rectal oh
my god
the healers had come upon nearly a
hundred objects buried as part of a
hexene ritual oh my God look at that
that's unbelievable hello hold it up for
me my god this is casting a spell over
someone this is haptic arnux of somebody
used to clean themselves so they put
some I belong another person that they
want to cast a spell over this is this
is all most of it is black magic though
is it evil just the the sense in the
feeling that I had of the the the people
men women children who were captured and
so to speak in those objects that are
intended to to to to break up marriages
or break up relationships or to bring
people together or more nefariously to
kill people and in people's lives there
was a horrible thing jeez
the healers felt they had to take action
and quickly
poor Alberto the mission suddenly turned
extremely dangerous when you break
spells and evil spirits are concerned
you are in danger
you're going into somebody's territory
somebody's domain it's obviously these
people happen to find out that you've
gone and destroyed something they've
done and they may try to do something to
you
I became physically I became I was ill
and everybody felt badly in one way or
another with so much evil concentrated
in one place
the healers felt their spirits were in
jeopardy doctors a Valletta suspended
his disbelief and agreed to be cleansed
Olympia to use the Spanish word ritual
sweeping and a cleansing to have
whatever might have attached itself to
us to take it off of us and hence make
us whole and put us back together what
his experience that day in that place
pushed aside science and challenged his
beliefs the effect where the real or
imagined was was very real on me and of
course an imagined effect or
psychologically emotionally induced a
fact that produces physiological change
is valid and it's real but I've seen
many things that I simply cannot explain
dr. Zabaleta story is not uncommon
science doesn't always conquer the
supernatural and for those who believe
witchcraft is all too real